gabby acuna contracted copit 19 in late
august it happened the very week she was
supposed to talk to her doctor about
getting the vaccine because she was
pregnant kate houston spoke to gabby's
sister about what must happen to save
her life
yes well this is 29 year old gabby acuna
just three months ago and this is her
now intubated with four tubes at
centennial hills hospital doctors know
that her lungs are deteriorating but due
to insurance she can't get a life-saving
transplant
it's a miracle that she's even
breathing at 26 weeks pregnant gabby
acuna delivered her son ryden via
emergency c-section he was only one
pound 10 ounces i never knew that little
babies could fight this hard
so we just need momma to catch up
gabby's sister paula omera says gabby
has survived a tracheotomy collapsed
lungs and cardiac arrest they came back
to us and they're like listen
gabby needs a lung transplant
it's like crucial these lungs are
they're done for she was approved for a
transplant in southern california as the
helicopter arrived the family found out
medicaid does not cover lung transplants
in nevada i still don't understand i
don't understand how it got that far
another roadblock is getting gabby to
sign documents that give them medical
power of attorney she's very aware she's
conscious i'm like i've explained all
the paperwork to her and she can say yes
they're now working to get her strong
enough to sign the form on her own and
she's making progress yesterday i was
like holding her hand i was like we're
dancing and she gave me like a little
smile and i was like there's my baby
girl there's my sister omeda is now
pleading for state officials to step in
to help her sister stay alive and raise
her firstborn son i know that
you know every system is a little broken
i know that
but maybe it takes an angel like gabi to
kind of just
make things
move in the right direction so maybe
it's not as broken
well gabby's family is raising money to
help pay for those medical costs that go
fund me is right here now if insurance
does end up covering all of the costs
they will donate this money to another
person needing a life-saving transplant
and we have reached out to the state
health officials and centennial hills
hospital to see what can be done we have
not yet heard back denise well kate as
you know the family tells her story in a
really emotional compelling video and we
posted that whole thing for you on our
website you can take a look at it at
8newsnow.com